hello
okay everyone in that corner for hammer
tags
hey
okay here's how you play
i have the hammer
and when i touch you with the hammer
you come sit in the middle until the
next round however if i drop the hammer
at all then everyone is free come out of
the middle and keep playing
or if i run in the middle on accident
everyone is free
get back outside and keep playing
yep
okay now
this is about
controlling and being aware of space do
you see this square yeah
it's between you and i
so try and keep that square between you
and i
if i go this way
if you guys run in the middle you're out
too
keep looking at me
okay now listen
you can't bump into each other look how
many people there are
that's part of the game you have to have
awareness because watch what happens
when i go this way
i can't stretch real fast that's when
you guys would crash into each other
so be careful when you change directions
are you guys ready yeah yeah
if you crash into each other if you have
no awareness you're in the middle too
ready game
very good zoey
you gotta keep looking at me
look out
um
yes
you guys
uh
got you